[THEME MUSIC]
JENNIFER VAN FOSSEN:
Welcome to Talks at Google.
I'm Jennifer Van
Fossen, and today we
are so lucky to have a group
of actors and actresses
with us from "Tully."
Please join me on stage.
We have Charlize
Theron, Mackenzie Davis,
Ron Livingston, and
director Jason Reitman.
[APPLAUSE]
We are so glad to have you
all here with us today.
CHARLIZE THERON: Are you?
JENNIFER VAN FOSSEN:
Thank you for joining us.
We really are.
Well, I saw the film last
week with my husband,
and gosh, there were so many
things that I could relate to,
being a parent, being a mom.
And the one thing that
struck me in particular
is there's this one
scene, Charlize,
where your character, Marlo,
is pulling into the parking lot
and trying to act like
everything is great and OK,
and she's struggling
with her kids.
And she walks, and I think it's
to the principal, and says,
oh, it's just such a blessing.
CHARLIZE THERON: Yeah.
JENNIFER VAN FOSSEN: And
this really is for all of you
but I'd love to
start off just by--
tell us about the importance
of that authenticity
in the characters that
you have in this film.
CHARLIZE THERON:
I mean, I guess--
I don't want to speak for
all of us, but I will.
[LAUGHING]
RON LIVINGSTONE: If I must.
CHARLIZE THERON: I think--
I mean, we definitely
all discussed just
how raw and honest this was,
this portrayal of parenthood.
That is definitely not
something that I've ever
read in a script.
And in my over 20
years of doing this,
I've might've partaken in that
false portray of motherhood
on film.
I think there was something
about this that was just so--
and maybe it's also different
now that I have kids.
I can't imagine making
this film before I had kids
because there was
so much of this
that I could just feel
inside my own bones.
And through all the
horror of the truth
of what it takes to
be a parent, there's
this utter beauty
that comes with it.
And I think that's what
definitely drew me to it.
I mean, Jason was a
really negative part
of deciding to do this
film, but the story really--
JASON REITMAN: Yeah,
it's one you [INAUDIBLE]..
CHARLIZE THERON:
Yeah, it was-- yeah,
it was like the
story's good enough
that I can deal
with Jason again.
JENNIFER VAN FOSSEN: Yeah, so--
JASON REITMAN: You're so brave.
CHARLIZE THERON: Yeah, I--
nobody knows how brave I am.
JENNIFER VAN FOSSEN:
Well, to that point
of dealing with
Jason again, this
is your third film
in what some have
said is even sort
of a trilogy, Jason,
with "Juno" and "Young Adult,"
which you did with Charlize.
JASON REITMAN: It's like
"Lord of the Rings."
JENNIFER VAN FOSSEN:
Just like that.
JASON REITMAN: Yeah.
JENNIFER VAN FOSSEN:
Yeah, so what's
important to you about
these three films
and the sequence
of them together?
JASON REITMAN: I mean, when
I met Diablo over a decade
ago now, I don't think I
could have ever guessed
that we were starting this
trajectory with each other,
that somehow we were going to
be in a kind of storytelling
marriage.
And now, of course, I
just hope it continues
for the rest of our
lives, and that we keep
on making movies like this.
I think--
RON LIVINGSTONE: Do you
remember your anniversary?
Because that's a big part of it.
JASON REITMAN: Oh, fuck.
I blew it already.
I remember the
first time we met.
We met at this place called
the Father's Daughter
over on Fairfax near the Grove,
and they have a bar in there.
And she ordered a dirty Martini.
I ordered a Diet
Coke, and it was
just very on par for our
relationship going forward.
But "Juno" was a movie
about growing up too fast,
and "Young Adult" was a
movie about growing up
a little too slow.
And this is a movie about
that moment when you realize
that you have to grow up.
And you have to turn
a chapter on your life
and create room so that your
child can occupy the space
that you were occupying.
JENNIFER VAN FOSSEN: And
tell us a little bit more
about what attracts you to
this and to Diablo's writing.
JASON REITMAN: You know,
it's funny, Charlize, Diablo,
and I are all
around the same age.
And although we came
from different places,
there's some sort
of connective tissue
that, when Diablo
writes a script,
she's articulating things
that we've all been feeling.
And there's something that
Diablo does really well,
where she writes about an idea
that we can all relate to,
which is not knowing
where you're supposed
to be in the arc of your life.
I think we all often have this
feeling like, am I behind?
Am I ahead?
Am I doing this
at the right time?
What was I supposed to
do by now at this age?
Whether it's work, with family,
have you bought a house yet?
Have you done this or that?
And so much of her
writing is about that,
and for whatever reason, I
think it connects all of us.
JENNIFER VAN FOSSEN:
Yeah, so to that point,
I'd love to speak to the
dynamic between the two
characters of Marlo and of
Tully, Mackenzie, which you
play, and the dynamics that you
explore in those relationships
between women.
There's episodes of judgment or
younger self versus older self
kind of feelings.
So tell me about the dynamic
between these two women.
MACKENZIE DAVIS: I mean,
it was an interesting role
to play because of the space
that it occupied in somebody
else's life and
trying to find out
how you can be your own shoulder
to cry on and support system
without becoming like a
really malevolent force
in that person's life.
I don't know.
I thought it was--
I mean, I think we'll just
reiterate the same things over
and over, but just a really
honest approach to how lovely
and shitty it can
be to be female.
And I haven't had
kids, but I have
been a woman my whole life.
And there were so
many things that it
felt like Diablo was telling
secrets from my own life,
and you were like
how do you know that?
And yeah, I just thought it was
a lovely female friendship that
was really honest
and not sugary sweet.
But-- do you want
to say anything?
CHARLIZE THERON: I mean,
having been the younger
one in the relationship--
[LAUGHING]
No, you said it so beautifully.
I totally agree with you.
I mean, I think Diablo doesn't
know how to not write honestly,
and I think she loves
that space where we all
live, whether you're
a woman or a man,
that's maybe not so pretty.
And I know for myself,
I'm very much--
I'm fascinated by that space.
And so to have a writer
and a filmmaker who
really wants to go and explore
that space, it's really--
it's heaven to get a job like
that where all of us get--
we get to live in the
skin of real people who
are going through maybe not
so nice things and maybe
are not behaving in
the best possible ways
that they could
in those moments.
But it's human, and it's
exploring that human condition,
and I love that.
JENNIFER VAN FOSSEN: One--
another moment, I
remember from the film
is there's an episode
in a coffee shop
where you are clearly
very, very pregnant,
and you're ordering a decaf.
And yet--
CHARLIZE THERON: How dare I?
How dare I?
JENNIFER VAN FOSSEN:
And yet you're
facing all this judgment from
this woman who's giving you
dirty looks, and can you talk
about that judgmental part
that you explore there, that
women do face pretty constantly
in society?
CHARLIZE THERON: Oh, yeah.
Yeah, I mean, I think that
we definitely live in a world
where we're just so hard,
especially on parents,
because all of a
sudden, they're carrying
this other little human.
And I feel like the
world almost feels
like they can step in and have
a judgment because it's not
really you.
It's that little person
that they don't even
know that's living
inside of you.
And I definitely
have been with--
I didn't have
pregnancies myself,
but just with my adopted kids.
I remember a mom
pulling me aside,
and she was like you should
not be using formula,
and I can hook you up with
some real breast milk.
And it was just like,
[SIGH],, and my kids
are fine as of right now.
They're still good.
They're doing OK on the formula.
JENNIFER VAN FOSSEN:
So I'd love to go
a little bit deeper on that
because the last movie that I
saw you in was "Atomic
Blonde," very different
type of a female character.
CHARLIZE THERON:
Little bit, yeah.
JENNIFER VAN FOSSEN: Yeah, it
was a real super, kick-ass spy
movie.
And you have a production
company, Denver and Delilah,
that was written up
in "Variety" not long
ago for really backing those
powerful female-centric
stories.
So can you talk a little bit
about how you pick your roles
and how your company
decides on its projects?
CHARLIZE THERON: Yeah, we have
a cool little thing going on
with Denver and Delilah.
We're definitely fortunate
enough to be in a place
where we do have
a little bit more
of a luxury, where we
can greenlight things
that might not get greenlit.
A film like "Atomic
Blonde" very easily
could have been a
male-driven film.
And to be able to have
a little bit of that,
to be in that position
where you can actually
take a film like that and
get a studio like Universal
to back it, that's a
really nice place to be in,
and I don't ever take
that for granted.
We're also trying to--
we do a lot of
television and film,
and so we're really trying to
not just, with female stories,
but really paying
attention to bringing women
into the positions that they're
just very strong in right now.
And so we have a
lot of projects that
are maybe not
directed by females,
but they're all
female producers.
And so I think being in
that position where you
can put your foot down, and--
I was just on a film that we
produced, and I walked on,
and our sound department
didn't have one woman on it.
And we had a bunch of
female actresses on it,
and I was like, guys, what-- no.
We need a lady here to be
dealing with the bra straps.
It's just a nice place to be
in, and for me as an actor,
it's not necessarily always
so that I can star in it.
It's nice that I can
take ownership and guide
a little bit of the stuff
that I do want to explore,
that you do get tired of
kind of waiting around
for a filmmaker or a writer
to come around and hand you
something like that.
So you can kind of step
in and develop things
that you're interested
in, and I love that.
And I like that it can-- that
I can be as diverse as I want
to be, and that, I think, is
one of the hardest things--
or was for me in my career.
You have garnered some
success in some genre,
and then that's all
everybody wants you to do.
And having a production company
gets me to do different things
and not regurgitate the same
thing over and over and over.
JENNIFER VAN FOSSEN:
Yeah, that's--
that seeking of diversity
in creativity and thought
and female centric is something
we really value at Google,
and I do on my team as well.
So thank you.
CHARLIZE THERON: Oh, cool.
JENNIFER VAN FOSSEN: Ron?
RON LIVINGSTONE: Yes?
JENNIFER VAN FOSSEN:
You're from Iowa.
RON LIVINGSTONE: I am.
JENNIFER VAN FOSSEN: And this
is personally important to me
because my husband's
in the audience,
and he's from Iowa as well.
So shout out to the Hawkeyes.
RON LIVINGSTONE:
[INAUDIBLE],, go Hawks.
JENNIFER VAN FOSSEN:
You have two daughters.
RON LIVINGSTONE: I do.
JENNIFER VAN FOSSEN: So tell
us from a male perspective--
so what's important to
you about this title?
And, Jason, I know you have a
daughter as well, I believe?
Yeah?
So I'd love to hear from you all
about what's important to you
about the female empowerment
from your perspective, too?
And Drew is Marlo's
husband in the title.
RON LIVINGSTONE:
Yeah, obviously,
because I'm raising two girls
to enter into the world,
I'd like the world to be
a welcoming and nice place
for them to be.
And I want them to
be valued, and I
want them to be empowered, and
I want them to feel strong.
They're pretty strong right now,
so I feel really good about it.
Yeah, and then the rest of
the stuff, I guess we'll--
I guess we'll get to.
What I like about this--
the way that this set up
is-- and you talked about
the authenticity--
is I feel like there's a
husband mold of what husbands
do in the child-rearing area.
And in real life, the
bar is a lot lower
than what you see in the movies.
In the movies, it's
like we give them
a lot of the benefit of
the doubt and credit.
And so this
character is really--
he's contributing closer
to what husbands generally
actually contribute and think
they're doing a great job.
So I don't know how that relates
to the female empowerment
element overall, but
it's a wife part.
I'm playing a wife part,
is what they would call it.
And it's kind of great
that it's flipped around
because I know my wife has
played a lot of wife parts
and made some wonderful
things out of them.
So that was a really
good challenge,
of I've got to take this
guy who's in a supportive
functioning role and figure out,
well, how can we make it real.
JENNIFER VAN FOSSEN: Anything
you would add there, Jason?
JASON REITMAN: I
mean, the funny thing
is that I'd really like to
make a movie for my daughter.
But I've made eight
movies so far,
and she hasn't seen any of
them because they're all rated
R or about teen pregnancy.
So I have a lot of
conversations waiting for me.
JENNIFER VAN FOSSEN: Got it.
Well, another thing I'd like
to touch on with you all is
you've--
and you've mentioned a
little bit of this, Charlize.
You've both done small
screen and big screen work,
and in my role here
at Google, I work
quite a bit with
the film studios
and also the broadcasters.
So I think it's
interesting what's
going on between small
and big screen these days,
and also, I think
it's really important
that these kind of stories make
it to the big screen still,
and it's not just a world
of sequels and blockbusters.
So I thought maybe
you all could talk--
JASON REITMAN: Though
this is a trilogy.
JENNIFER VAN FOSSEN:
Yes, that's true--
well, that's true.
That's true, but with
unique characters, yeah.
So I'd love to just talk
about how do we encourage
and make sure that
these types of stories
are told on the
big screen as well.
RON LIVINGSTONE: I
mean, the best way
to do it is to make them.
I mean, that's, I
think, the first step.
And that's-- thank
God you're doing that.
I don't really feel that there's
that much of a difference.
The camera's the same
size in any case,
but whether it's a big
screen or a small screen,
that stuff all comes later.
I feel like when--
you're probably maybe
thinking about that,
but when I show
up to work, it's--
I'm not thinking
about the screen.
And I think people have
a great relationship--
I feel like the
difference-- and people
have some pretty big screens
in their houses now, too.
JENNIFER VAN
FOSSEN: That's true.
RON LIVINGSTONE: And there's
going to be a lot of people who
watch this on-- they'll
download it or--
JASON REITMAN: Their phone.
RON LIVINGSTONE: Yeah, or
they'll pirate it or something.
Yeah, exactly.
So yeah-- to me,
I think it's more
of a thing of when
the big screen still
has that place for
this is an event.
We're going to give
this our evening.
We're going to get
out of our house.
We're going to go sit down,
buy expensive popcorn,
and we're locked into this.
We can't flip the channel
if we don't like it.
We can walk out, but that's
a very dramatic thing.
So it's-- yeah, it's nice
that we're giving adult fare,
I think, I guess,
if you're an adult.
JENNIFER VAN FOSSEN: So it's not
so much about the screen then.
It's about the
projects getting made
and the stories being
told regardless.
JASON REITMAN: I hope we hold
onto the collective experience.
That's the important thing.
I think there's a
lot of conversations
about screens and sound, and
that's all well and good.
It's nice, although I find I
go to the movies all the time,
and I think, man, why
won't they turn this up?
I wish they would play
movies louder in theaters
and change the bulbs in
the projectors more often,
but I'm also a nerd.
But what I think is important
is the collective experience,
is you go to the movies, you're
with a bunch of strangers,
and you're all laughing together
or you're all crying together.
You're all being moved together.
You're all realizing
something together,
and that is a very
rare experience.
I think it's an
important experience.
I mean, it certainly has
been throughout my childhood.
I love movies.
I try going to the movies as
many times a week as possible.
And by the way, I love
television, and I watch a lot,
and I binge a lot as well.
I think it's a great
form of entertainment.
What I'd hate to lose, though,
is the collective experience
that doesn't only happen for
movies like "Black Panther,"
but also happens for tiny movies
that can really change minds
and move us because there's
something different about
watching a movie at home alone
and having that experience--
which is moving,
but it's alone--
and having it as a community
with people you don't know.
You all showed up
at this theater
from maybe all
parts of the city.
You all come from
different lives,
and now, you're all
laughing together.
And I think the thing that I
fear losing the most is that.
JENNIFER VAN FOSSEN:
That's a great point.
So if the audience
wants to get ready,
I think we're going to
do a little bit of Q&A
if you guys want to
get ready for that.
And I'm curious,
Jason, is there a movie
that was like that for you?
Can you think back?
JASON REITMAN: I mean, a
movie theater experience?
JENNIFER VAN FOSSEN:
Yeah, that collective--
JASON REITMAN: I mean,
there's a hundred,
but I remember lining up
to see "Pulp Fiction,"
and I was in high school.
And that was one of the
great nights of my life.
I mean, I think about
that night the way
that people think about
lining up for some show
at CBGB's in the
'70s or something.
That was a life changer.
JENNIFER VAN FOSSEN: Yeah.
How about the rest of you?
Can you think of a title
that was really moving?
CHARLIZE THERON: I just--
I was sharing this with Jason,
and I think my friend is here
who's a producer on this, too.
Beth Kono and I went to
go see "Shape of Water,"
and we're both kind of
dead inside as people.
We don't have a lot of emotion.
And I started crying
so uncontrollably.
I was literally, like, oh, my
god, this is so embarrassing,
and then I just looked
over, and she was crying,
and I was like, thank you.
Thank you.
I'm not a weirdo.
But it's like Jason said.
I could have never
experienced that at home,
and it's nice to have that
conversation after, too.
The credits start rolling,
and you start talking about it
collectively, and there's
something nice about that.
And I do think sometimes people
have experiences-- they watch
films at home, and they don't
have the same experience
that you do when you're in
that theater with other people.
Something happens.
Maybe it's the
expensive popcorn.
I don't know, but something
definitely happens.
For me, it did.
I'm not dead, turns out.
JASON REITMAN: OK.
[LAUGHING]
RON LIVINGSTONE: I saw "Star
Wars" as a fifth grader,
and it kind of rocked my world,
not only just the spectacle
and the way it just
kind of exploded.
There wasn't anything
like that before, and then
all of a sudden, there was.
But I feel like just the--
all the mythical stuff,
it's like a primer
in eastern philoso--
Taoism basically, and zen.
And that has lasting effects.
I think it's cheesy to say
I think it changed my life,
but yeah, it had to have.
CHARLIZE THERON: "Star
Wars" changed your life.
RON LIVINGSTONE: "Star
Wars" changed my life.
CHARLIZE THERON: I get it.
MACKENZIE DAVIS: My local--
this is not like that at all.
My local movie theater is
this really old dingy place,
and I think it's where they
shoot those night vision
examples, where they do
screeners of scary movies,
and people are throwing
their popcorn up
because they're so scared.
And I saw "It" there, the
one that just came out,
and I had to wait in line
that wrapped around the block.
And it was a 30-minute wait,
and then it was just 11-
to 17-year-olds.
And we all watched "It"
together, and it was so--
it felt religious,
where everybody screamed
at the same time, and then
you'd turn to the stranger
and be like, [LAUGHING].
It was so fun to be
in that space again,
and it just reminds
you, you don't--
because all you get at
home is sort of like, mm,
but not the full cathartic
scream and communal energy
thing.
JASON REITMAN: There's something
about a scary movie when
the person next to you is
scared, the energy transfers.
MACKENZIE DAVIS: And you do--
the scream-to-laugh ratio is
on par, and it's so fun and
weird because you're like
[LAUGHING].
CHARLIZE THERON: So
shall we open it up now?
AUDIENCE: Thank you
all so much for coming.
I was able to watch
the film earlier today,
and while I'd like to think that
the magic of Diablo's script
was part of this,
I'm really curious
for Mackenzie and Charlize.
It has an-- I don't
want to spoiler alert,
but it has such an
unusual twist at the end.
I was not expecting
it, and I just
thought you two
were so separate,
but then so connected.
How did you develop that?
Because that magic just
wasn't in the script.
CHARLIZE THERON: We
slept with each other.
MACKENZIE DAVIS: And it
was awkward at first,
but then it just broke down
this barrier right away.
CHARLIZE THERON: It helped.
MACKENZIE DAVIS: Yeah.
To know someone's
body like that is--
CHARLIZE THERON:
Especially that body.
There's a lot to explore there.
I've been very lucky.
Jason is really, really
good at casting, obviously.
No, but seriously, he's
just so good at casting.
I remember when we did "Young
Adult" together, he only
brought up one name, and
it was Patton Oswalt.
And I didn't know who
Patton Oswalt was,
so I was a little bit
like, ooh, who's this?
And then he showed me some
stuff, and I was like, really?
And then we got on set, and
it was like, oh, god, that's--
you just see something.
And so this time around,
it was the same thing.
The only name that was ever
brought up was Mackenzie,
and I mean, for me, when I
read the script, because it
was so intricate, this
relationship between us,
I definitely read
it in that sense.
And so I was like, that's
going to be interesting.
What do you do with this?
And Mackenzie showed
up, and it was just
so beautifully weird and odd.
And pretty much from the
moment that I met her,
I was just like this, and so
it was perfect for the film.
And then she ends up--
she's a cool girl, so it was
nice to be on set with her
and to share this
experience with her.
MACKENZIE DAVIS: Thank you.
CHARLIZE THERON: You're welcome.
MACKENZIE DAVIS: Yeah, I feel
like we didn't plan anything
out too much.
We just talked a bit about--
I remember that
breakfast that we
had in that weird hotel
in the Sutton Hotel,
where we just talked
about getting older
in a really normal way.
I don't know.
We have the same
body type, and what
it's like to be used to
the way your body behaves
for your whole
life, and then what
happens when it starts behaving
in a different way, and just
simple things that can bond
you to someone quite easily
and make you--
I don't know.
There's certain-- this
sounds like something that
"Cosmopolitan Magazine" would
say, but there are something--
certain secrets of being
female that can make you
feel very close to
someone immediately
without needing to map out
a whole plan right away.
CHARLIZE THERON: I think she's
also one of the funniest people
I've ever been around, and
so that's just so disarming.
And I think, instantly, we
really connected on that.
I was just-- every time
I was around, I was--
because I was not the
funnest person on the shoot.
I dealt with depression for
the first time in my life,
and my body was just not
happy, and my mind was unhappy,
and my soul was unhappy.
And being around her was just
real joy, and I think we--
I definitely got-- whether
she liked it or not,
I got close to her through that.
I was very happy when she--
Ron, I was happy when
you were there, too.
RON LIVINGSTONE: OK, it was OK.
CHARLIZE THERON: I was happy
when you were there, too.
RON LIVINGSTONE: Sure.
CHARLIZE THERON:
In a different way.
RON LIVINGSTONE: Yeah.
CHARLIZE THERON: I love Ron.
RON LIVINGSTONE:
Different body type.
CHARLIZE THERON: I--
[LAUGHING]
MACKENZIE DAVIS:
Different body--
you don't know what it's like.
CHARLIZE THERON:
Ron is, by the way,
the nicest person you will ever
meet on the face of the earth,
hands down.
Way nicer than you.
So I'll just point
out you guys' best--
MACKENZIE DAVIS: As foils.
CHARLIZE THERON: Yes.
JENNIFER VAN FOSSEN:
Go ahead, Emma.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
guys for being here.
I'm just curious, was it
hard to get this movie made,
given that it's a
movie about motherhood
and being a new parent
and multiple kids?
Was this a hard one to pitch?
Or do you feel like there's
an appetite for that right
now, how much we're
exploring motherhood,
and you're seeing it
more in shows and films?
JASON REITMAN: I don't think--
they're traditionally
not easy to get financed,
and I don't think they're--
I have not heard of any
studio out there saying,
you know what, let's look
for more real human drama,
particularly female human drama.
That's-- although you're right.
There's a lot more of that
happening in television now.
I think-- frankly, a
company called BRON Studios
up in Vancouver
financed this film.
And they came in early,
and they came in strong.
They liked the script.
They loved this cast, clearly,
and they backed the film.
And they were amazing
start to finish.
There was never any kind of--
I never felt them trying to
bend it into something that it
wasn't.
The people that were
already big fans
of "Juno" and
"Young Adult--" they
got the tone of what we wanted
to do, and we got it made.
But I feel lucky about that.
I think we're very
fortunate that we
got to get this film made.
There's a lot of
films like it that
are trying to get made that
are not getting the financing.
If only we were at a company
with a limitless amount
of funds that could invest
into movies of tomorrow.
I would think if they
really cared about women,
they would start investing money
into female-driven independent
film.
Huh.
CHARLIZE THERON: I like that.
AUDIENCE: My question goes to
Jason because I'm an aspiring
filmmaker, and I'm--
I haven't got a chance to see
the movie yet because it's
released on May 4th--
May the Force be
with you, by the way.
Anyway--
JASON REITMAN: It's within
the "Star Wars" universe.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, pretty much.
CHARLIZE THERON: It's
a Tolkien crossover.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
I'm just really curious to know
what your directing process is
like, from getting the script
in your hands to development,
pre-production, post-production,
to distribution--
how much was changed?
What was left--
what was left in?
What was left out?
And how-- and through
those changes, how
did you define the characters
from point A to point B?
And what was it like to
pick out the color palette
for cinematography and
choosing the appropriate lenses
to tell the story?
I'm sorry.
JASON REITMAN: These
are a lot of-- these
are all great questions.
It's a lot of them,
and I think if I
were to answer all of that,
it would take a while.
And I'm going to.
So-- no.
So I'll just say a
couple of brief things.
One, what's unique about Diablo
is that she is a pure writer
and does not use index
cards or treatments.
She has an idea.
She called me at
one point and said,
I have this idea for a
movie, and she kind of
told it to me in two sentences.
And then six weeks later,
she had a screenplay,
and it was a first draft, but
it was also our shooting draft.
And she just writes.
She sits down and starts
at the first scene, then
the second scene, and she
lets the movie tell her
what its going to be.
And that's how she's
written all her films.
And as another writer,
it's infuriating.
I mean, it took me seven years
to write "Up in the Air."
I don't know-- I don't
know how she does it.
But her screenplays are
very clear on the page,
and it's not to say
that they are loaded
with long paragraphs of detail.
They're very succinct.
They're very short--
100-page scripts.
But you can't help but read
it and know what she's saying
and what she's referring to.
I feel like it's my job not to
tell the actors how to do it.
It's to find people
who I think have
connective tissue with the
characters on the page.
Not that they're the
same human being,
but there's something inside
them that connects them
to this character that I know
is going to come to life.
And then they bring it
to life, and I'm there
to help shape and keep us
all within one tonal world.
But it's up to them,
and we don't rehearse.
We-- and it's funny
you brought that up.
We had one lunch before
we went because I'm lucky.
I get to work with brilliant
actors, and I know, on the day,
we're going to find it.
And we're going to find it
over a few takes, or maybe
a few more takes, but it's not
going to be anything crazy.
And when that magic
happens, when two actors--
when two really talented actors
suddenly connect and have
chemistry, and the
lines come to life,
there's nothing like
it in the world.
I mean, it's really an exciting
thing to watch happen live,
and when it happens, I
want the cameras to be on.
I don't want to be in
a rehearsal studio.
So that's a little bit of
how the process was, and it
certainly is how this
movie came together.
JENNIFER VAN FOSSEN: I think
we have one more question,
and then we'll wrap up.
AUDIENCE: So Charlize
and Ron, I think of you
both as really funny
people who play characters
with a lot of pain, but
really funny characters
with a lot of pain.
But you also do some
wackier characters,
and I'm sort of curious,
as artists and performers,
do you feel like that
balance is important?
Or do you lean one
way or the other,
that it's important
to you to play
characters who have some sort
of non-comedic painful depth?
RON LIVINGSTONE: Wow,
that's a great question.
You want to take that?
Or--
CHARLIZE THERON: No,
I could go after you.
RON LIVINGSTONE: All right.
You know what, I'm
going to assume
my male privilege to go first.
[LAUGHING]
CHARLIZE THERON: I'm
handling it to you.
RON LIVINGSTONE: I-- it's like--
I think the pain is--
everybody has pain.
And so if it's useful to
bring it to the thing,
then that's great.
As far as the wacky, I just--
I think I'm just kind of goofy.
There's an element of
me that's kind of goofy.
And there was a while-- there
was five years when I was
trying to be a matinee idol
and wear the leather jacket--
I mean, like I have on now.
And it was just really hard not
to make a face because there's
something about it that
strikes me as a little silly.
And then that's the part that
I like about it, is OK, what's
the silly part?
But I think it's all the same.
You know what I mean?
It's like people who are only in
pain or only trying to be funny
tend to be really infuriating
people to hang out with,
so you just throw
it all together
and see what comes out of it.
CHARLIZE THERON: Yeah, I
mean, I agree with Ron.
I don't believe that
people are only one thing.
I think that--
I think that's also what
makes this writing feel
so great because it deals with
some very serious and hard
subject matter, but
through real people.
And I think real people--
I think we can all
relate to that.
I've had shitloads of
tragedy, but nobody is just
that one thing.
And I think a lot of people
who have had a lot of tragedy
in their life tend to veer
more towards the silly
and the light-heartedness
of it in order to survive.
I mean, this is why
I'm dead inside.
Didn't work for me.
But I think there's a
sense of humor about this
that feels very real.
That's not just a joke for the
sake of a joke or to be funny.
I think a lot of the
humor of this film
comes from very
real places, and I
know for myself,
raising my kids,
it is a horror movie and
a comedy with Will Ferrell
and "Star Wars."
It's everything.
It's literally
every day, I'm like,
I don't know what
movie we're in today,
but can't wait to go on the
ride, see where it lands.
I don't know.
Does that-- is that--
RON LIVINGSTONE: That was great.
CHARLIZE THERON: That
was a bullshit answer.
JASON REITMAN: I
thought it was good.
CHARLIZE THERON: I don't--
RON LIVINGSTONE: Yeah.
JASON REITMAN: I'm satisfied.
CHARLIZE THERON: I don't know.
I don't know.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]--
CHARLIZE THERON: You just
do what he says, basically.
That's really what happens.
AUDIENCE: Me, personally?
Or just--
CHARLIZE THERON: No,
what Jason [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
JASON REITMAN: Yeah, we've
been waiting for you to--
CHARLIZE THERON: Yes,
I'm waiting for you
to tell me how to respond.
JENNIFER VAN FOSSEN:
Reminder, May 4, everyone,
please take your friends.
Go see "Tully" in theaters.
Thank you so much
for making this film.
CHARLIZE THERON:
Thanks for having us.
[APPLAUSE]